- I think the answer right
now to everything is more.
- [Man In Hat] Yeah.
- You know, everyone's
like what should I do
for my personal brand?
I'm like as much as possible.
If you can do a daily podcast, yes.
If you can do a vlog, yes.
If you can post five times
a day on Instagram, yes.
If you can do 30 posts for stories
for Instagram and Snapchat, yes.
If you can reply to 50
people on Twitter...
Like to me the answer is yes
and so what the vlog does...
So for example the post that
I personally just posted
on Instagram is, I'll show
you exactly how it works.
You'll find it interesting.
So this post that I just posted
is something I said to a question, right?
The way it actually works
is, as soon as, I get so many texts.
It's gotten slow.
I gotta figure it out.
So my team is on here.
Right?
So here's how it works.
I'll get a text like this
from somebody on the team
from things I've said, right?
So I said this in DailyVee 455, right?
And then I'll reply with
only the ones I like.
Two and four, and then you know,
hours later or first thing tomorrow,
I'll get
that.
- [Man In Hat] Yeah.
- Got it?
- [Man In Hat] Yeah, yeah, yeah. I got it.
This is what I was like asking.
I want to know how
big is it...
- I think the right
number for somebody who's
(motor noise)
like really going for it, is six.
What do you think, Du-rak?
- [Cameraman] Depends on
what you're talking about
(muffled)
- Yeah.
Right?
I mean if we really, if we
really weren't building it
for VaynerTalent, for
VaynerMedia, if we were just me,
we'd probably be six, right?
One paid, one video, one
writer, one audio, one designer.
It would be tight. Six.
I mean six is crazy.
Like, I don't know anybody
who has six for one person.
- [Cameraman] It was
three in the beginning.
- Yeah, it was, it was just
me for seven years, you know?
- [Man In Hat] Yeah, but
I trust that the higher,
like my personal v-log fee-mer.
- Yes.
- [Man In Hat] So...
- That's gonna help a lot.
What the vlog did was
opened up everything else.
It opened up everything else.
Now I don't,
I document, I don't create.
Right?
So even this clip, even this, is very meta
because now it might be
titled for Facebook like,
"How Somebody Should Be
Thinking About Building
"Out Their Team" and here it is.
I didn't have to sit and
write, you know what I mean?
- [Man In Hat] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Or, I don't have a writer right now.
He moved on to another opportunity
but I'm not hiring one.
Now this could be a LinkedIn
post and she or he could
listen to his whole thing,
write it in first person,
then they'll call me and ask
me two or three more questions,
I'll answer, and now you got an article.
Because I think they all matter.
Written word, audio, video,
pictures, all of it matters.
- [Man In Hat] But that's the (muffled)
Because I'm creating
like a sort of (muffled)
like I do movies and then
I do lots of comedic clips.
- Yes.
- [Man In Hat] So I create
but I need to also (muffled).
- Correct.
- [Man In Hat] (muffled)
We did it like
one time in an accident we was doing v-log
when we was filming the movie
and movie took off like this.
And now...
- You're like, ah...
- [Man In Hat] But when you say...
- I totally get it.
I totally get it.
(chill music)